In the Caribbean, it's always summer.
The vibe is easy, the rum's smooth and the beach is crowned by golden sunsets.
But scratch the surface and you'll discover something more.
Ancient Mayans built vast cities here and Dr. No stashed his secret lair.
Pirates once called it home.
Sugar barons still do.
With more than 7,000 islands....
...sprinkled like emeralds across 1,200 miles of turquoise water,...
...you can hunt big game fish, hike the mossy trail of a cloud forest...
...and shop the glitziest boutiques.
See the Caribbean the Norwegian way and you won't just get a tan;...
...you'll inhabit paradise, if only for a while.
With sailings in 2012 from Miami, Tampa, New Orleans and New York,...
...we have itineraries that make it simple for you to choose...
...the distinct island vacation you want.